i i really hope that people also
if they read it realize this is not a
book
that is meant to overcoddle the
millennials or gen z
this is truly believing that this is the
alpha infrastructure
to building significantly large
successful businesses
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
it is very clear to me
25 years into my career
that
kindness
and empathy
and patience
and humility are actually the
foundations and i think the things that
all of us think about as soft skills
and emotional intelligence
are actually
the hard skills that it is far easier
for me to find
people who are good at the task
or have good math skills than it is to
find people who are capable of being the
bigger woman or bigger man in the face
of pressure or adversity
and so
for 20 years or so this has been in my
subconscious
code
like for many of us gave me a time to
reflect and i immediately went into
writing the book
on a couple of reasons one
i'm incredibly aware that there's a lot
of young people paying attention to my
moves
are fans of what i do
and i thought it would be a
disservice if i wasn't incredibly
aggressive in my communication
on the things that i see as a winning
formula
it becomes double important when i
realized that most people don't talk
about kindness
as the single alpha skill in building a
successful empire
and i thought it was a unique take it's
also very nuanced the reason the
subtitle is ingredients is when i was
going through my process i realized oh i
never just deploy empathy i never just
deploy patients in every situation
it's actually three or four different
traits often traits that are in a
conflict with each other
it's very interesting to be tenacious
and ambitious
while being patient
and so i i liked the concept of
ingredients because it's like cooking a
meal i think we all believe that sweet
and sour chicken is something that is
delicious but sweet and sour can see a
conflict so
i felt that i was the right person at
the right time
and what has transpired in the last 18
months because i wrote the book very
quickly in the beginning of kovid
obviously takes time for it to come out
and things of that nature
many of us are thinking about things in
the business world around the concept of
the great resignation
and
and the concept of people even applying
into businesses in the first place in a
world of options
i think
the
importance of being a leader that
understands these traits has even
compounded
in the last 18 months since i even wrote
it which feels serendipitous and
exciting for me and
i i really hope that people also
if they read it realize this is not a
book
that is meant to over cuddle the
millennials or gen z
this is truly believing that this is the
alpha
infrastructure
to building significantly large
successful businesses
what i love is this refreshing take on
leadership and i can speak from a
woman's perspective that
many of us have mimicked
this ideal hard leadership
because that was the architect that was
what was you know the right leadership
and you're taking the narrative into a
different direction
and so
what would you say to those who would
point to entitlements of industries and
say well this is not
you know how they were maybe this is not
what you described in the world
look i believe that you can have
short-term success in many ways and i
believe that the world has been very
clear to us over the last centuries that
fear and negativity are sometimes a fuel
for short-term success
you know my argument is that
it's not as powerful as brightness and
love that
that hate is a powerful trait
uh
but i just believe it never beats love
in the end and i believe that to be true
in business of course there have been
people who've been successful who are
not kind leaders
that
doesn't mean that it should be mimicked
and i would also ask
if you have the luxury of interacting
with people in their 80s and 90s and
especially those who've had major
financial success
by being
mean
and negative
i think you'll find that many 80 90 year
olds who've built their empire with
darkness have incredible levels of
regret and actually lived quite unhappy
lives
and so
my question simply to business people is
is the money worth the
unhappiness you talk a lot about empathy
and kindness and i think probably the
times that we've gone through the last
couple of years with everything that's
happening in the world we need more
kindness and empathy than ever
and the question here is how do you
deploy these attributes without
enabling that behavior with that
well i think first of all people want
everybody else to be kind and empathetic
so my favorite part of this book is
accountability
you know everyone has become incredibly
good at judging others
the world is addicted to pointing
fingers
i have never
seen the world louder about telling
everybody else what they're bad at
so i think the way to deploy
successful kindness and empathy is to
actually start with yourself i also want
to remind everybody that deploying
kindness when the other person is kind
to you
is very easy
i challenge the world to start having a
conversation with itself
of does it have the ability to be kind
and empathetic
in the face
of negativity
my leaders are incredibly kind to my
employees when everything's going well
i don't need
peace time generals
i need leaders when things are bad and
hectic to be able to be the bigger woman
and bigger man in that situation to
create a framework of kindness and
empathy
so
you know for me
it's about the accountability of being
able to be that person
right now we are in a world where
everyone is so quick to get triggered
by bad behavior that they fight fire
with fire which is why so little is
being accomplished in society in
politics and in the workforce
and so for me
i think that we are not spending enough
time with our thumbs
and we need to stop being addicted to
our fingers
one of the things you speak about is
self-awareness which is
foundational to any evolution of us as
human beings tell us a bit about that
and how do we where do we start with
self-awareness
this is hard the concept of teaching
someone to be more self-aware is
something i've been thinking about for a
long time
you know i think the thing that drives
so many of us crazy in the world is
interacting with those that struggle
with self-awareness
i think one of the hardest things for
people to deal with is hypocrisy
we struggle with it and i struggle with
it um
[Music]
the exercise in the book that i decided
to do was
creating frameworks for the people that
know you the best
to create a safe space for them to be
able to tell you the truth
i think one of the
reasons
people struggle with self-awareness is
because they have enablers around them
that are allowing them to get away with
bad behavior
and so i'm spending a lot of time trying
to think about how one
puts the people that knows them the best
in a safe place to actually give them
the critical feedback that could be the
jarror of a journey towards
self-awareness
it's a very tough challenge i don't know
if i have the answer
what i can tell you is
no question the business leaders
that i admire the human beings that i
admire
are the ones who are off the charts in
self-awareness i'm incredibly grateful
for the luck of the dna game that i
think gave me a lot of it i would argue
that the only reason i have any level of
popularity is because of self-awareness
because of the kind of communicator i am
and my personality i would be
completely not palpable if i didn't have
high levels of self-awareness because i
have some really funny attributes as a
communicator and so
it's a conversation we need more of
i do think that self-awareness has a
very interesting relationship with
accountability
i think that a lot of people actually
know
what their shortcomings are
but
they try to navigate the world
in a way where they are hoping that
people don't notice
and
it's something i'm thinking a lot about
one of the things i actually loved in
the book is the part where you talk
about relationship with tom yes and you
hear often people say it's too late for
me to start a new business to move my
career to mary whatever that may be so
the love for you give us that
perspective
the rules of the world right now on when
you should have your life figured out
when
you should
be married
have children
make money buy a home and everything
else
are based completely on when people live
to 45 and 55 years old
period
the rules of our society have not
changed in a very long time of
expectation
on what we should be doing with our
lives
the problem with that is
we're living to a hundred
the concept that a 25 year old should
have everything figured out
is
laughable
most 60 year olds i know don't have
their life figured out
why are 25 year olds putting such
pressure
i think that we have societally done a
very poor job to our youth
which gets me to a place that's even
more emotional for me which is we must
challenge
the notion
that so many parents in the world
use their kids success
as their own self-esteem
what that does is it pressures children
into short term behaviors around
education
occupation
and relationships that are often
missteps
based on very small windows of time
one of the great reasons i struggle with
the way that education is sold in our
society is we train kids from a very
young age that you will be judged every
90 days on your actions
i think it leads to
very
very vulnerable behavior that maps to
our adulthood
so
yes
i think that
way too many people are judging
themselves in the short term yes i
believe that if you are 63 years old you
still have 30 years to achieve
fulfillment and happiness
and i think it's time that we have a
totally different conversation around
age to the point where in actuality the
fact that we pressure children into
starting to get serious at 22
is actually ludicrous 22 to 30 should be
wild
wild high risk high reward behavior
because it's practical because even if
you blow it and nothing goes well you
can start getting serious at 30 35
and so we ask people to now you're a
grown-up get a real job and all this
other
ludicrous behavior
that i think has really hurt society i
think
i think a lot of it is predicated on
outside affirmation
i think many people start doing things
for validation from strangers
or their parents or others and i think
we have to have more thoughtful
conversations about it i think it's i i
think it's quite
[Music]
depressing for lack of a better word
that there are people that are 40 years
old still have 60 years
ahead of them and they think it's over
i think that needs to stop
so one of the things that surprised me
in the book
that's because garyvee the guy that sits
up here is the king of candor
i shoot it straight as an arrow when i'm
talking to the world
but when gary vaynerchuk the executive
is sitting across from an employee that
he loves and he's scared to tell her or
him that they're bad at their job
because he fears that that's going to
put them into a spiral of being scared
that they're about to be fired is a
lesson that has taken me over 20 years
to learn
when i when i started really reflecting
on why
in a world where i
really don't care about the money
why would i have any employee that has
ever worked with me be unhappy with me
and i had to look in the mirror and
realize that the greatest shortcoming of
my life let alone my professional career
has my been my inability to be candorous
about my opinions and feelings
which has led to subconscious and then
conscious resentment towards that
individual
which has led to conflict which has led
to me randomly firing somebody out of
left field for them even though i
thought they should have known all along
that was a very difficult thing for me
to come to grips with because my
greatest pride
as a leader is the elimination of fear
when i realized that my lack of candor
was actually creating macro fear because
nobody actually knew where they stood
with me it was one of the darkest days
of my career but it was also one of the
greatest days of my career because it
started the process of me starting to
figure it out and me being vulnerable
and putting it in my book for everyone
to see
especially when my reputation as a
content creator is that is my strength
was an important step in my own
evolution
and what happened
actually about that space
reading
reading facebook groups of former
employees that worked for me saying i
was a jerk
it's incredibly challenging for me i i
genuinely don't like money enough
to have people not like me i don't know
what else to tell you it's a complete
brain twist for me that this could be
and i finally had to take on
accountability
because it was very easy for me to blame
poor performers because everybody around
them also thought they sucked
so it was easy for me to justify like
they were tone deaf they weren't
self-aware but the reality is i never
gave them a chance to fix it because i
wasn't willing to give them constructive
criticism
and
i
really so much of my strengths and so
much of this book is
really just a story
of a boy who idolizes his mom
but his mom also isn't great at candor
and he picked up on that as well who
also had a father who was exceptional at
candor but his delivery of that candor
was so terrible that he demonized the
candor without realizing it was the
vehicle that the candor was being
delivered in that was the problem not
the candor and so that was a process of
self-reflection and experience and
for all the kids in here no matter how
great you think you are and i thought i
was super great at 22.
let me give you a preview the gray hairs
come with some value
so on
another another
optimism
so
[Music]
well this is where the ingredients come
into play
my optimism comes from gratitude
when you are grateful for what you have
versus envious for what you don't have
optimism comes second nature
life is always going to be challenging
but perspective is something we all need
a lot more of we sit here today in this
gorgeous room
while 850 million
almost 10 percent of the world
does not have access
to clean water
850 million people in
this world do not have access to clean
water
i have not been able to put the pieces
together
to be upset about a business deal going
awry
in a world where 850 million other
people don't have access to clean water
i am dumbfounded by people's inability
to be grateful for what they have for me
optimism is second nature because i'm
completely based in fundamental
gratitude
and
i wish more people
were too
and that's why i like talking about
gratitude
[Music]
those attributes the crispy they are
beautifully selected and the way that
you put those ingredients together
actually are so practical in terms of
how one can use this this book to evolve
and to kind of really
it's incredibly important especially for
those in here who don't have a lot of
context on me i've been listening to the
first 10 15 minutes of this
let there be no confusion i am a
full-pledged operator i am only grounded
in practicality for 22 of the last years
i have been responsible to make payroll
100 on my own back
everything i'm talking about right now
is the framework for those successes yet
i could be very empathetic that somebody
listening right now may think that this
is a very optimistic delusional
ideology
that is why i wrote the book
this is the furthest thing
from delusion
but society for over 100 years of
business have told all of you that the
things i'm talking about almost have no
place in business or is a very nice to
have as long as you have all the other
skills i promise you all those other
skills are a commodity the reason most
businesses fail is because they're
incapable of firing the people
that are producing dollars but are
destroying morale
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
this is a great question i believe that
we are born with a lot of our traits
i believe we are then parented and some
of the traits go up and down i believe
we are environments of our neighborhood
our country our culture
when i tell you the thing that comes
least natural to me in the world
is candor one on one and for me to see
where i am today as a 46 year old man
everybody in this room has the ability
to grow in many of these attributes
most don't want to put in the work
most would prefer not to do the things
that come hard to them
most would hope that it goes unnoticed
nothing goes unnoticed
people may not tell you
but nothing goes unnoticed
i believe in the human spirit the world
is very black and white to be on this
one people evolve people change people
can get stronger at certain things
people can get weaker at certain things
and so
i am incredibly optimistic
on human's capacity
to
evolve
what it requires
is first acknowledging its truth
seeing it
one of the reasons i
produce the content that i produce
is with the hopes that just one when i
do this right now
literally when i tell you
that i'm just hopeful that one person in
this room
is listening and something triggers
one
because that's profound
saying
a couple of sentences
that shift
a person's perspective which allows them
to start building
towards
a better place for themselves and the
people they love
is a great gift and i take on that
responsibility and i think everybody in
this room
who is fortunate enough to be in a happy
place
has a requirement
to start communicating it because we
live in a world today where negativity
is incredibly loud
and positivity tends to be silent
and i think if you are positive
you have an obligation to your fellow
man to communicate it and make it louder
[Applause]
yeah these microphones that are lined up
here excite me to no end i hope that
tons of people
i hope tons of people are is that how
we're doing it people are going to come
up to mike please i mean i see a lot of
hands line up and there's a lot of mics
let's line up and do it
thank you
okay i used to be
remember uh one day i was punished by
the company being compassionate um where
they came up to me and they're like
you're supposed to do your job when i
was looking after someone
that was the day i decided that i don't
want to do this
i was looking at your content all these
days and that was my trigger point and i
decided to pursue photography on the
weekends and now it's been four years
i've done that full time freelancer
[Applause]
what i'm trying to do is i want to get
most
and i regard myself as a very
compassionate person so much so that
sometimes i want to help my
friends to get into this space and i'm
unable to do that because of their
minorities and their responsibilities
how do you because i know about general
people
explain to yeah but with your with your
friends and families how do you come to
terms that you can't do so much for
everyone
because i deploy
patients
everyone's on a different time schedule
one of the great things that works for
me is a lack of expectations
you know
i want everybody that i ever talk to to
see what i see
i'm also incredibly aware that that is
not going to be the case
on my timeline
you've got to realize that
even though you're coming from a
beautiful place the energy that you're
talking about right now is selfish
you want to feel the endorphin
hit of bringing value to somebody you
love which is a wild concept to realize
that it's selfish
all you can do
is stay consistent with your
communication
i mean there are certain things that i
taught my father
that took me 26 years to accomplish
if you love them you won't stop
communicating
[Applause]
[Music]
my question
and
is
so much
content and time to everything else
thank you for saying that a couple ways
one
i am very passionate about giving back
giving back comes in the form of
financial give back but ironically i
believe the biggest way that i give back
is by being
intellectually generous
by putting out all my content to the
world for free
um
bringing people value and so i
compromise some of my operational upside
on my selfish side
because i allocate more time
to put out content to the world
comma
i'm incredibly operationally strong and
i figured out
many years ago that if i just filmed
every moment of my life even though in
the beginning it was going to be very
weird
that it was a more efficient model for
me to create content that i can share to
the world i am one of the most prolific
content creators in the world
and i never sit down and do content
i just actually live my life and it's
just filmed and so
i think it comes from the ambition to
give back
and from being actually a good operator
cheers
extra free books
cheers
hi gary
how are you
uh
my name is ben
and i have a
simple question for you
which tricks me a lot
like
is it better to sit
to get in the car and start driving
or
knowing where to go
[Music]
that's a really fun question
i believe the answer is very individual
i believe if you're the kind of person
that has spent too much time thinking
about where to go
then it's time to get in the car and
start driving
i believe that if you're a person that
continues to drive and you have no idea
where you're going that it's time to
pull over and give some thought to think
about where you're going
you